Польща. Сучасна країна в центрі Європи.
Однак останніми роками це також країна, де зростає ненависть до представників ЛГБТК.
Ставлення у суспільстві останнім часом погіршилося. Насамперед ненависть.
Раніше це не настільки проявлялося, тепер це майже норма, це виходить за будь-які рамки.
Інтернет переповнений гомофобними коментарями і відбувається дедалі більше нападів на цьому підґрунті.
Торік такі випадки траплялися навіть у Варшаві.
Понад 100 польських громад оголосили себе так званими "зонами вільними від ЛГБТК", це майже третина Польщі.
Пояснюють це тим, що у такий спосіб буцімто захищають своїх громадян від згубної західної ідеології.
Зокрема заборонена будь-яка реклама з сексуальними меншинами.
Але є і спротив. Стати на такий шлях ризикнув бренд одягу з Варшави - Risk ("ризик").
Творці бренду хочуть висловити політичний меседж - своєю веселковою колекцією.
Політично-суспільне становище в Польщі стало складнішим. Дехто скаржиться на утиски.
Ми хочемо не лише про це говорити, але й щось зробити проти цього. Щось, що впадає у вічі. Тож ми розвинули з цієї ідеї цілу колекцію.
Власне, ми ще раніше мали такі наміри.
Колекція виникла у співпраці з неурядовою громадською організацією, яка захищає права представників ЛГБТК.
Гадаю, така рекламна кампанія, такий громадський рух необхідні, оскільки гомофобія уже стала повсякденним явищем.
Я у захваті, що існують польські марки, які щось подібне роблять на підтримку ЛГБТК. Як на мене, це чудово.
Великі концерни, на кшталт Ikea або Ben and Jerrys також підтримують ЛГБТК-спільноту своїми глобальними рекламними кампаніями.
ЛГБТК-реклама у Польщі - це як щось інопланетне. Їх стає більше, але все ще вкрай мало.
Звісно, існують підприємства, які підтримуються ЛГБТК-спільноту, але їх дуже мало, і це як крапля в морі. Це лише 20-30 підприємств.
У бренді Risk хочуть продовжити свою веселкову колекцію, частина прибутку піде на підтримку ЛГБТК-організацій.
Колекція добре розкуповується, тож у виграші і бренд одягу, і сексменшини.
Гадаю, наш крок не мав впливу на наші продажі. Частина клієнтів відмовилася від нас,
але натомість прийшли нові, які почули про нас завдяки цій кампанії і підтримали її.
Клієнти - переважно мешканці великих міст: заможні, проєвропейські і ліберальні.
Марка представила у соцмережах кампанію про стосунки людей з різними сексуальними орієнтаціями. Малка Кафка - одна з моделей.
Гетеронормальність - це не єдина сексуальна орієнтація. Але на наших вулицях видно лише тих, хто думає, що це єдино правильна орієнтація.
Тому моя товаришка та я вирішили взяти участь у цій кампанії, щоб показати, що і в нас є не лише "гетеронормальні" люди.
Таким чином активісти хочуть підбадьорити інші фірми долучатися до акцій на підтримку ЛГБТК.